hi everyone happy comic-con week you
probably just saw the news Marvel and
ABC just cancelled agents of shield is
gonna end after next season they're
finishing the last few episodes of
season six right now season seven will
have 13 episodes air next year and then
that's it all the characters that don't
die will permanently go to Tahiti so
without spilling any tea I'll explain
the story of why they're ending it now
and how it lasted this long and behind
the scenes Marvel drama and why you've
never seen any of the TV characters make
it into the movies spoiler warning for
the spider-man far from home post
credits scene in case you haven't seen
spider-man far from home yet but when
you think about what Nick Fury is doing
and what it means for Marvel phase 4
it'll make a little more sense how
Marvel as a company Marvel Studios is
transitioning away from earth-based
stuff so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the comic-con
videos is gonna be crazy there's a new
round of the IMAX ticket giveaway - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a Marvel comment on
the video I'll also explain what's going
on with the timeline in the events of
agents of shield right now between
Avengers infinity war in Avengers
endgame which is breaking down top-10
style number 10 rewind to the events of
the original Avengers movie Joss Whedon
is hired after they've already started
working on the movie he's forced to do a
rewrite of that while they're shooting
around a couple big action scenes at the
time Marvel Studios was still under the
control of Marvel CEO Isaac Perlmutter
who is said to have been very hands-on
and very difficult to work with
when Kevin Feige was trying to develop
the Marvel Cinematic Universe now this
is around early Marvel phase 1 era
heading into the first Avengers film
long term they solved that problem when
Disney bought Marvel and then made
Marvel Studios its own self-contained
division giving Kevin Feige total
control over the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the movies they developed
that didn't happen till right after
Avengers age of Ultron tale and Marvel
phase 2 so already they've done a whole
bunch of films but 9 the original
Avengers movie blew up at the box office
huge like everyone expected and Marvel
early on in their relationship with
Disney were making tons of money off of
toy sales but there was so much Marvel
IP and characters going
use the powers that be a Marvel and
Disney wanted to start exploiting that
through TV shows and create a TV
division if you can believe it most big
studios earn more money on all their TV
shows than they do on their movies
so naturally Marvel and Disney wanted to
get on some of that action but ate the
creation of the TV division had nothing
to do with Kevin Feige he was off
working on Avengers age of Ultron and
developing the rest of the early Marvel
phase 3 movies because the Marvel movies
are the crown jewel of that brand Kevin
Feige typically gets to decide where
characters go is this a character that
can go to a TV show or is this a
character that can only be in the movies
as you would expect all the most
bankable big characters that have big
toy sales big merchandise sellers all
bookmarked for the movies only all the
TV shows get to pick from the bargain
bin in characters and ideas for stories
that Kevin Feige said he probably never
be interested in which is where you get
to agents of shield because Kevin Feige
was getting ready to destroy that
organization in the MCU so it wasn't
gonna be around your okay fine make a TV
show with that because we're not gonna
be using it we didn't had also killed
off the Coulson character so he was free
to be used too but very rare example of
a movie character going onto the TV
shows seven around that time Joss Whedon
with the success of the first Avengers
film was hired to a much bigger contract
at Marvel to write and direct Avengers
age of Ultron to oversee all their
Marvel films in phase 2 and phase 3 in a
creative sense and to develop TV shows
because he comes from TV the Buffyverse
is one of the first things people
usually remember him for
so while Joss Whedon is developing
Avengers age of Ultron he also starts
developing his first Marvel TV project
which would become agents of shield that
started right after the first Avengers
movie hit theaters 6 you go 2 months
later during the early stages of
Avengers age of Ultron pre-production
Kevin Feige in the Marvel producers are
going back and forth with Joss Whedon on
the details of the movie while that's
happening he starts talking to them
about his agents of shield project like
I got this TV show that I'm developing
in the way the Joss Whedon spills his
tea in the most recent interview that
he's done is that the powers that be at
Marvel Studios the movie people weren't
necessarily pissed off at him that's
probably not the right word for it they
kind of thought that the TV stuff that
he was
working on was a waste of time like why
are you working on this TV show stuff
when we really hired you to develop this
multi-billion dollar movie Avengers age
of Ultron so already you're kind of
getting the sense that the Marvel movie
people are treating TV show stuff like a
completely separate universe they don't
wanna have anything to do with it they
don't want to deal with it but number 5
Disney and ABC wanted a Marvel show on
the air so they were gonna make that
agents of shield show no matter what the
movie people wanted Joss Whedon to do so
Whedon was forced to stop being the
showrunner in hand the project off to
his younger brother Jed Whedon and his
wife who had previously worked with him
on dollhouse and the other Whedon verse
shows that he'd done so at this point
he's totally checked out of the show in
fully just focusing on movies stuff
that's why you know wait say like
daredevil Luke Cage all the Netflix
characters contractual cooling-off
period ends and they start showing up an
MCU projects they'll probably be totally
rebooted versions of the characters
because Kevin Feige and the movie people
clearly do not like dealing with stuff
that they didn't originate so whatever
version of daredevil you see again is
gonna be completely from the MCU people
for totally awesome guy Kevin Feige
early on in the process also goes to
Joss Whedon and tells him what they're
doing in Captain America Winter Soldier
like you know what this agents of shield
TV show idea you have is great I'm sure
you're having fun working on it but you
know we're getting ready to destroy the
basis for your TV show in our next movie
so we're sort of rendering your show
pointless like why would you call it
agents of shield if we're gonna blow up
shield halfway through your first season
it doesn't make any sense all the TV
show people working on the episodes had
no idea that that was going to happen
save for like one or two people at the
top so you start to see some of the
problems they have in trying to do this
connected universe and really why it
wasn't meant to be connected in the
first place three that's why in later
seasons you saw the agents of shield
people distancing themselves story wise
from the MCU stuff there were a few
minor crossovers never any real big
a-list Avengers I think Sam Jackson's
Nick Fury cameo during the first season
for like a second is probably the
biggest thing that they've ever done
with a movie actor but the movies never
did anything with the TV characters so
it's a very one-sided relationship so
when talking about Captain America Civil
War the writers Christopher Markus and
Stephen
Fillie who'd been riding Marvel films
all the way since the first Captain
America films they've been in the MCU
doing movies for a long time they said
that at no point had they ever seen any
episodes of agents of shield nor been
asked to look at putting those
characters in any of their movies and so
they also wore Avengers Infinity Ward
Avengers endgame so that's why you never
saw any of the TV characters in the
movies is because nobody working on any
of the movies really cared at all about
what was going on in the TV shows too
during the early years the show is you
all probably saw bombed in its first
season on ABC critically it was skating
by it had a small audience and ABC
wanted to make their money back that
they've spent developing the show in
order to turn a profit TV shows
typically need to do between 50 and 100
episodes
most of that money now comes from
streamers like Netflix who pay millions
of dollars in licensing fees so a lot of
times even if a show gets really
terrible ratings on TV that would
normally get it cancelled if they know
they're gonna make a lot of money from
Netflix deals
they'll keep making the show no matter
how small it is but because Disney is
doing the Disney plus streaming service
they're gonna lose out on a lot of that
licensing money because they're pulling
all their content from Netflix and on to
the Disney Plus streaming service so one
of the big nails in the coffin for
Shield is the low ratings and now losing
that Netflix deal
heading into season five ABC wanted to
cancel the TV show knowing that this was
going to happen so that's why they wrote
their season 5 finale to coincide with
Avengers infinity war in the snap so
that they could give everyone a version
of a happy ending then just snap
everyone and it would be a really cool
WTF way to go out and to somewhat
integrate with what's going on in the
biggest Marvel movie of all time after
the fact though Disney put pressure on
ABC to renew the show so ABC was kind of
backed into a corner and gave them two
more seasons of 13 episodes per season
so that takes them through their season
7 in number 1 that's why after they sat
down to discuss what they were gonna do
for the story for next season on shield
they decided that they would do it as
the final season that way they can write
all the episodes knowing that it's going
to be the last they can kill off any
characters that they want but it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're going to
be doing any big movie crossovers so I
wouldn't expect any really big
cameos from movie characters on agents
of shield maybe outside chance of a Sam
Jackson cameo to sort of bookend his
cameo from the first season the other
real big nail in the coffin for shield
is also the Avengers TV shows that Kevin
Feige in the Marvel Studios people are
developing hopefully that explains why
they decided to cancel the show and why
it's lasted this long and why there
haven't been any big movie crossovers in
terms of timeline the stuff that's
happening on agents of shield right now
this season is happening a year after
the snap and Avengers infinity war in
nowhere on the show have they really
referenced the snap or talked about any
of that stuff
so clearly they're trying to avoid all
the movie stuff full-on at this point
what'll probably happen is is I'll do a
video for the eventual finale because it
has been on for seven seasons they've
done a couple cool things the Ghost
Rider character is getting a spinoff TV
show on Hulu so if you really like Ghost
Rider on agents of shield he's getting
his own show pretty soon the big Marvel
phase four panel is happening Saturday
night but there's even more trailers
dropping tomorrow on Fridays I'm posting
this video as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all the videos when I post them and I
have a bookmark at the top of my youtube
channel with all the Comic Con videos
that I'm posting so you should see all
the videos there too even if you don't
get the alerts congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big video
Sean the man won please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for that brand
new Thor Ford teaser and click here for
my Avengers and game deleted scenes and
blu-ray bonus features video thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome happy Comic Con week
[Music]